en russie la situation sanitaire est
préoccupante les courbes ont du mal à
s'inverser et la rentrée de septembre
inquiète les autorités la correspondante
à moscou d'entonner claireaux il ya une
semaine encore la russie a enregistré un
nouveau record de mort quotidienne
globalement depuis la mi août ce chiffre
tourne autour des 800 morts par jour le
nombre de nouveaux cas lui est en baisse
depuis la mi juillet mais pourrait bien
repartir à la hausse dans les prochaines
semaines en cause le mois de septembre
la rentrée avec tout ce que cela
implique de brassage de population cela
a lieu tous les ans et il est
parfaitement évident qu'il existe là une
régularité épidémiologique tous les ans
lorsque les gens reviennent de vacances
et les enfants retournent à l'école pour
diverses raisons épidémiologiques et
virologiques
le fait est que les gens se remettent en
groupe il ne s'agit pas de nouveau
groupe mais parfois c'est le cas aussi
il en résulte d'une augmentation
significative des cas d'infections
virales respiratoires dans la deuxième
décade de septembre le vice ministre de
la santé a qualifié la situation de
gérable en soulignant la facilité
d'accès à la vaccination et ce sur
l'ensemble du territoire russe mais le
problème reste le faible pourcentage de
population vaccinée en effet seuls 30%
des russes ont reçu au moins une
première injection